a former louisville police officer
linked to the killing of brianna taylor
has been found not guilty on charges he
endangered others during the botched
police raid brett hankinson fired 10
shots into a neighboring apartment
during the 2020 drug raid he was fired
from the force and could have been
sentenced to 15 years in prison if he
had been found guilty our national
correspondent jerica duncan has more
jerica good morning good morning nate
hegason and his defense team argued that
he was doing his job and only fired the
shots because he thought his fellow
officers were in danger now the kentucky
jury deliberated for about three hours
hankerson shook and looked relieved as
the not guilty verdict was read his
attorneys say they are thrilled
remaining adamant that he did nothing
wrong in march of 2020 hankinson and
other police officers armed with a no
knock warrant broke into taylor's
louisville apartment looking for an
alleged drug dealer neither taylor nor
her boyfriend kenneth walker were the
targets of the raid walker says he
mistook the cops for intruders and fired
his gun police returned fire 32 times
none of the bullets hankinson fired hit
briana taylor taylor's family left the
courtroom without speaking but her
sister posted on facebook that she's
quote tired of this injustice and called
the legal system a failure meanwhile
family attorney ben crump called it
further evidence of the lack of police
accountability no officers have been
charged with killing briana taylor and a
federal investigation is ongoing to
determine if any of the officers should
be charged with violating taylor's civil
rights nate
tarika thank you it's a little
perplexing because his own department
the louisville police department said
that he quote wantonly and blindly yes
fired into the apartment and they fired
fired him so i don't know how you can on
the one hand your own cops are saying
wantingly and blindly but the justice
the legal system
sees it differently it's it's perplexing
for for non-experts for sure so imagine
once again the taylor family feels no
justice here walking away empty yeah
yeah eureka we appreciate you thank you